[Music]
partner on taught me Lehren hit the
streets of Los Angeles to find out what
people really know about socialism watch
this little thing called socialism yes
what do you think about it I love it
that's social what do you love about it
I like to socialize with everybody
they're not socialized socialism I'm not
really sure what socialism actually is
so socialism is basically an economic
system and where everybody's equal
there's no rich and there's no oh no I
get it's kind of like what Cuba does I'm
not quite so clear on the exact
definition of socialism but I think it's
important that it isn't just every man
for himself
I don't know because socialism's worked
in some places I don't know you know the
difference between a Democrat and a
socialist honestly no how do you feel
about socialism sir it's great I just
got back from here four weeks in Europe
free health care good schools it's
wonderful
free free everything you think that
workers have to pay for it recent poll
just came out saying that Democrats now
view socialism more favorably than they
view capitalism what are your thoughts
doesn't make any sense socialism is
ridiculous I'm for it you're for
socialism I am for it why because I
think everybody should have a fair
opportunity for health care and yeah
this fair mean free fair means free you
hear any your friends talking about
socialism nope they don't talk about
politics at all nope yeah Bernie Sanders
is yes
he believes in socialism
Bernie Sanders supporter I don't like
Donald Trump so why not anything not
Donald Trump is okay yep there are some
Democrats mostly who believe socialism
should replace capitalism do you think
that's ever gonna happen
personally I do not think that's ever
gonna happen
I think capitalism is fantastic it gives
every American an opportunity to earn an
income to people got it right - it was
reaction on throw the brand-new book why
we fight Fox News national security
strategist dr. Sebastian gorko and
former Secret Service agent NRA TV
contributor dan bungee know his brother
I met today is much better-looking and
smarter than him I'm just teasing dr.
korkor let's start with you your what's
your reaction to that because that is
the modern Democratic Party it's
stunning Shawn we're both old enough to
remember November the 9th 1989 where
thanks to the good offices of Ronald
Reagan Margaret Thatcher and st. John
Paul the second the captive people of
East Germany with their own hands took
down the Berlin Wall we thought
communism socialism had had a stake
driven through its heart but it's like
those zombies in those horror movies
it's coming back and these people don't
know I mean Ocasio Cortez Bernie Sanders
don't know that Lenin and Marx said
socialism is just the way point on on on
the on the way to communism communism is
the objective of socialism is what Lenin
said and the stunning thing is Margaret
Thatcher was right
socialism is great until you run out of
everybody else's money just like you've
seen Venezuela sure I used the same
chord often and we're running out of
people other people's money damn Bonjean
oh and it's kind of shocking I mean
there's there's a pretty big percentage
of the electorate that I don't think
really understands the difference now
they don't have reminded of that scene
from Billy Madison you know we're all
Dumber for having seen that Shawn
socialism is not free stuff socialism is
death
it's despair its starvation it is the
government control the means of
production Europe and Denmark and
Scandinavian and Nordic countries are
not socialist socialism is for imbeciles
don't be an imbecile
these are capitalist countries with high
taxes if you want to argue about taxes
we can argue with the left about taxes
but Denmark Scandinavia and Europe these
are not socialist countries these are
capitalist economies where the
government does not own the means of
production it just taxes the snot out of
its citizens I wish these people would
wake up and read a book talk to Gorka
yeah this this is the great myth none of
these countries are socialist countries
the land of BMW in Germany the land of
Volvo in Sweden the land of Nokia sorry
these are capitalist capitalist states
that tax their people a lot but aren't
communist states and out socialist
states and and the other thing is we've
protected them for seventy years so they
have the capacity to choose butter over
guns now they're in trouble when they
have to defend themselves so it's a
fantasy land it's Alice in Wonderland
Shaun you both get a plus tonight
quoting Margaret Thatcher and dr. Walker
and taxing the snot out of them damp on
Jeana and I did meet my brother today he
is better looking smarter and younger
just saying yeah is that smarter he's
definitely better-looking